with that we have
a speaker who has repeatedly been at the
new york conference and is the first
time we have gotten him to
the uh dc government conference
really exciting he does a lot of
political science work and he does a lot
of forecasting on elections
so we're going to hear how he did
whether he
nailed it did terrible or got somewhere
in between this year's election
there's so many things i could say about
him from
uh from the greatest living statistician
that's not gonna make him nervous
to a fun teacher to everything we could
talk about
everyone please welcome andrew gilman
it's a pleasure to speak in washington
dc uh even though i can't
be there myself i grew up in the suburbs
of dc
and my parents both both worked for the
government
i'm in non-supervisory capabilities
um but nonetheless they were um
they did and i i just want to thank
all of you for all of your public
service
i would like to thank the previous
speaker also for his service
i have never been in the military but
when i was a student i did work at the
naval research lab
in washington dc right next to the
sewage treatment plant for a few years
and i learned a lot of
science there too so
today i wanted to talk briefly about
election forecasting and it was fun
writing the
title of the talk because i sent the
talk title in october
before the election had occurred so i
titled it how we succeeded brilliantly
failed miserably or landed somewhere in
between
which seemed like it covered everything
except people don't really like that
landed somewhere in between part like
everyone wants things to either succeed
brilliantly or fail miserably
and one of the messages we have in
statistics
is that um things aren't
binary in that way well the election's
binary there there's a winner and a
loser
um public opinion is not binary um
science is not binary and the success of
a forecast is not binary
one of the problems with people's
perceptions of election forecasts
is that they swing back and forth
between thinking that a forecast
succeeded brilliantly
and that it failed miserably so um
people are overreacting in both
directions now before the forecast
occurred
i was going around telling people well i
i
i i was going around telling people that
um i hope that our forecast is perfect
because it'll make us look good but then
after that happens i want to explain to
people how we just got lucky
and as this is this is what i wrote at
the time i i posted something after
sending jared the
abstract that
i wrote our model could fail miserably
for example if joe biden wins alabama
which we say has less than a 1
chance of happening joe biden did not
win alabama
or it could um or could land somewhere
in between
for example if biden wins the electoral
college but with just 51
of the popular vote which is at the end
of our forecast interval
well biden actually got about 52 of the
popular vote
so it was within our our forecast
interval but it can't really succeed
brilliantly
even if our model correctly predicts 49
states or whatever that's as much luck
as anything else is there estimates of
margins of error
well the funny thing is our model did
predict 49 states correctly
but but and and i don't want to go
around telling people so i was all
prepared for
the model's going to predict 49 states
correctly people are all going to say
our forecast was perfect
and i was gonna have to explain to
people that it wasn't but of course i
don't need to explain that because
everyone knows that the forecast wasn't
perfect
um in understanding
so in understanding what went wrong with
the election forecast
i want to do two things first i want to
tell you what went right with the
forecast
and then second i want to tell you the
information that was used in
constructing the forecast
then we can think for looking forward
about how how we can do better
um so what went right about the forecast
well we we said we thought biden was
going to get 54 and a half percent of
the vote and he got about 52 percent of
52 and a half percent of the vote
so our forecast was off by two
percentage points at the national level
and it was off by more than two percent
in some states and less than two percent
in some other states uh what was
of course you know it's not going to be
perfect so what was right about the
forecast was that it had a margin of
error
that accounted for things possibly going
wrong
as indeed they did
now um
given that we have to say what
information went into the forecast
so to forecast the presidential election
we use
several sources of information the
first is fundamentals so predicting the
national election outcome
based on national op based on
national political and economic
conditions so that would be the state of
the economy
for example is measured using per capita
economic growth during the year
preceding the election
of political fundamentals such as
whether the incumbent is running for
re-election
uh and um the
popularity to the approval of the
president uh in the months before the
campaign
now incumbency is interesting here from
a statistical
perspective because incumbency comes
into the model
not so much as a main effect but as an
interaction
and what i mean by that is when an
income history seems to show
and logic theory and logic also would
imply
that the impact in forecasting the
election of economic and political
fundamentals
is larger when an incumbent is running
for re-election
than when he's not so because the
incumbent president was running for
reelection
that suggested that um the the poor
economy and his low approval
would give him a gives a low forecast
for how
how well the incumbent was going to do
how well trump would do in the election
now the only tricky part about this is
that over the years
in recent years we think fundamentals
are less important because of political
polarization
so for example in 1984
um ronald reagan got 60
of the vote well there was an economic
boom at the time
but i don't think that if you were to if
you were to have a similar economic boom
now you would get a candidate getting 60
of the vote because the the two parties
are just too
isolated and there are just too many
democrats who are not going to vote for
republican and too many republicans who
are not going to vote for the democrat
so that's included in our model that the
fundamentals matter but not as much as
before
the second part of our model is the
relative positions of the states
so if you can predict the national
election and you know the relative
positions of the states
then you should be able to put then you
should be able to predict
um the election for each state and of
course that was very important
everyone anticipated before providing to
win
the electoral college he was going to
have to win something like 52 percent of
the vote
which is what happened and we know that
because from one election to the next
the relative positions of the states
don't shift by very much
the third piece of information is
national
polls so uh the fundamental space
forecast has a big margin of error to it
uh the polls we can use bayesian
inference to partially pool
between the poles and the and the
fundamentals
the next piece of information
is a time series model because
a poll is a snapshot not a forecast
so if we have if it's september 1st and
we're making a forecast of the election
we have polls up to september um
our fundamentals model is predicting
what's going to happen on november 3rd i
think that's what election day was or
november 4th whatever it was
the fundamentals models predicting
what's happening on election day in
november
uh to link the data to the election
we have to have a time series model of
how public if communion can vary from
day to day
and the next the final piece of
information that's in our model are the
state polls
state polls are kind of overrated in
importance in some way
we pretty much already know the relative
positions of the states
before the election is even going to
occur they don't
state polls don't provide us much
information beyond the national polls
but they provide a little bit of
information
then um in connecting we need in a
statistical model we need to connect the
data to the underlying thing we care
about
the polls are measures of public opinion
but we know from
historical data that the polls can be
off
we found that the error the empirical
error in the poll is about
twice the stated margin of error and not
only can poles be off
but pulse can be off in a correlated way
so having a hundred poles doesn't mean
that your standard
error goes down by the square root of
100
i could have a million poles but all the
polls could be off and indeed
in the this election the polls in
aggregate were off by about
about two or three percentage points
more in some states and less than others
um now there's some interesting
statistical research
here which is under trying to understand
how our model is going to work
um and so we've we've been we haven't
published any of this yet
but we've been playing around with ideas
like refitting the model
where you take some data out or where
you take some data and shift the data
um and to see what the to see what the
inferences look like
and people sometimes will talk about the
impact of one particular poll on the
forecast
but that's not really important one
particular poll doesn't tell you that
much but what about all the polls
together so
we um the reason why we landed somewhere
in between we did not succeed
brilliantly because there was systematic
error in the polls
and we allowed for the possibility of
systematic
error in the polls but we didn't have a
statement about which direction the
error would be in
in previous elections sometimes the
polls have favored the democrats
sometimes the polls have favored the
republicans
we followed a kind of economic argument
which is that the survey
organizations are motivated to be
accurate in their inferences
and so as a result we wouldn't expect
there to be a bias in one direction or
another
or to put it another way we expect there
to be some bias but we wouldn't know
ahead of time
what that would be we
think the reason why the polls were off
was because of
non-response differential non-response
that republicans
were less likely to to republican voters
were less likely to respond to the polls
and democratic voters even after
adjusting for
demographics some polls also adjust for
party identification and how you voted
in the previous election
but even then it seemed that there is
differential non-response
um possibly having to do with people who
vote differently than their party
identification or with independence
the other difference is voter turnout
and so it seems i
i i think we're it's still we still
don't know the full story
but there's uh it seems
that
redem republicans were doing more voter
registration and in-person campaigning
and democrats weren't and some of that
did show up in new voter registration
numbers
also it's possible that the
well-publicized early voting by the
democrats
motivated more republicans to then show
up on election day to
counter that so of course an election is
a is a dynamic
system and finally the reason why we
landed somewhere in between it did not
fail miserably
is because we were historically
motivated and allowed for the
possibility that the polls could be off
now when preparing this
forecast it has all the moving parts we
thought a lot about how this information
is communicated and we did a lot of
like simulations as i said of our own
forecast and we
we examined others as as well
um and we learned a lot
so it's interesting in the forecasting
world
it's generally accepted that people have
a motivation to be overconfident
and so i always give the example of the
auto mechanic
so if you take your car the auto
mechanic
you you it's not running right he'll say
oh yeah there's a problem with
xyz and then you leave the car there and
then you come back the next day and he
says well
it wasn't xyz it was this other thing
but don't worry i fixed it and you pay
him and everybody's happy
if you go the auto mechanic and you say
what's wrong and he says i have no idea
you might just go to a different auto
mechanic
and and then when you talk about doctors
sometimes people say you're actually
paying for the certainty more than
anything else
so there are a lot of motivations this
as a statistician i spend a lot of time
fighting this motivation to be
overconfident
it's just very easy to people want you
to be so being overconfident is like
saying i love you
like people it just you always in in any
relationship you're kind of in pressure
to say i love you because you get
immediate positive
feedback um but yet you know you
shouldn't just go around telling people
you love them all the time right
and so similarly it's so tempting when
giving a forecast to go into pundit mode
and say i am sure and if you're a
statistician well i know i'm not
supposed to
say i'm sure so going into pundit mode
would be putting out numbers and saying
well the probability is 58
or or whatever it is and we have to be
careful about that so as a statistician
i'm always criticizing
scientists for writing papers where they
say we've discovered this we're sure of
this
and like then when things don't
replicate then people are like oh yeah
well not everything replicates and
and then like why were you so sure
before we didn't really mean it we're
just saying that
so we don't want to be like that right
you don't want to be that guy
who's always overconfident in election
forecasting though
forecasters got burned by some previous
elections
people are surprised by things so
sometimes there's a motivation to be
underconfident
because um so imagine what you're you're
a forecaster and what you do is produce
50
intervals for a living and people stare
at your 50
intervals well every time the truth is
inside the interval you succeeded and
what's outside the interval you failed
so that creates a kind of economic
motivation to supply 50
intervals that are too wide so that
they're more likely to contain the true
value
if your 50 intervals have 70 coverage
then it looks like you succeeded 70
of the time well of course someone could
check but
with elections there aren't that many
ways to check it was
it was funny because the the 538 website
had a chart where they showed the
calibration of their forecasts based on
their election forecasts
based on hundreds of thousands of
forecasts
now you might wonder where they got
hundreds of thousands of elections
they've only actually been running for
something like six elections
so they got hundreds of thousands by
looking at all 50 states and getting the
forecast for every day
for every state but they're not
independent events
right so you don't you don't really have
that so
we can't really evaluate the calibration
um that's why i said
your your forecast can fail miserably
but it can't succeed brilliantly in the
same way
that is if my interval is this
and the actual election outcome is way
out here then i failed miserably right
so
if my 90 min our 90 our 95
interval for biden's vote share was
something like
51 and a half percent to 57 and a half
percent
centered at 54 something like that and
the truth was like 52
52 and a half percent the national level
um so let's like that's the way it goes
right if our inter if that had been our
interval and biden had only got 49
percent of the national vote
or if he got 60 of the national vote
then you could say we were we were way
off
so there's this motivation to always
make your interval a little bit wider
just in case
but that's okay you should just be aware
of that the complicated thing
where the math comes in is that
to make oh i should say we did
everything in r
and so that's why this is the r
conference we used
r and we use stan um
it's um
the way the math comes in here it's
tricky is that
we don't just forecast the national
popular vote we
forecast the state votes
now i i keep saying if you forecast the
national popular vote and then you
assume that
the relative positions of the states are
known you're going to get
like almost all the way there but people
want the separate state forecast so
that's fine
um when you combine you can think of
having 50 state forecasts which you
aggregate to get a national popular vote
forecast and to get an electoral vote
forecast
and we
noticed something which was that
we knew we wanted a certain width to the
national forecast like we had a sense
historically of how far things could be
off like
we would not want our forecast to have
been 54
and a half percent of plus or minus one
percent that would have been too narrow
and so we also can get we have
inferences for the states from state
pulse and if you assume that
if you if you have 50 different states
and you assume the state errors are
independent of each other
or close to independent of each other
then when you have reasonable state
uncertainties
then your national uncertainty is way
too narrow
so in order if you don't want an
unreasonably low national uncertainty
you have to either make your state
uncertainties very wide or you have to
put high correlations between the state
uncertainties
and a high correlation means that you
just that if
if biden did better than expected in one
state you expect he did better and
than expected in other states and
we found from that it was interesting so
we we knew this because we had worked
really hard and we did it
wrong at first we had to change our
model because our intervals were too
narrow and we realized that our
correlations were too low
and they didn't truly affect represent
our uncertainty
um but then we did notice um the the
forecast on the 538 website
and the national the state forecasts
were way too wide
so they had joe biden having a six
percent chance of winning south dakota
which was really never going to happen
and they had biden having naya trump
having a chance to win new jersey and
california and all sorts of other things
and we realized what had happened was
they
because their correlations between
states were too low
they had to make the state errors really
large in order to get a reasonable
national error
and like the way i'm describing it i
hope it all makes sense and it all comes
out right
but when you're actually building it
with all these moving parts it's it's
not so clear and i think what happened
to them
was they kept adding new features to
their model and they ended up with this
wide uncertainty which didn't make sense
but then
like so what if trump is if biden has a
six percent chance of winning south
dakota he's not going to win it anyway
like it's
it so what i want to say to you
i want to end a message to you because i
think that
you and your work i should have said
this at the beginning
so pretend i said this at the beginning
all of you are forecasters
all statisticians are forecasters even
if you don't think that's your job
it is even if you're only doing
exploratory data analysis
people are doing it because they're
interested in what's going to happen
next even if you think you're doing
causal inference causal inference is a
forecast for what could happen
given what treatments are occurring
right whatever you're doing
you're doing forecasts and it's very
hard to get all the dimensions of a
forecast right
if i'm only forecasting the national
election that's kind of easy
i mean it's not easy to get it precise i
have a big standard error but i just say
that's all i can do
but when you're doing a complicated
forecast like if it was a business and
you're forecasting sales in many
different divisions
or if you're a government agency you
know maybe you're forecasting
recidivism among many different groups
of people
maybe you're forecasting uh uptake to a
new government program
you're forecasting something it's
multi-dimensional it's very hard to get
that all working
at once i think bayesian inference is
the way to do it but it still depends on
the model and whatever you try first
isn't going to work
wherever you try second isn't going to
work then you're going to find that the
forecast is wrong in the dimension that
you care about and you have to fix
other parts of the forecast and then you
do that and it makes other things not
work this is kind of what happened to us
what happened with 538
what i want to say to you to conclude is
i want you to embrace
that process i want you
when you're i want you to take your
forecast and look at all the weird
things
like all that look at the weird corners
of the map
and all the places where you made a map
and there's a discontinuity across
states and it shouldn't be and that's
because one of your state level
predictors is wrong
whatever it is when you see a problem
you can't necessarily fix it because
you're under a time constraint so when
you write your report
you should say this is my forecast and i
stand by it but no i don't really think
trump i don't really think biden has a
six percent
chance of winning south dakota we just
haven't fixed that part yet like be
open embrace it because that's how
you're gonna learn
right if you accept this is like you
know like
you are a sinner you know like when you
accept that you are a sinner
then you can do better if you come in
thinking your forecast is going to be
perfect you're going to mess up
but once you realize it's going to be
wrong and you can admit it
then you can learn from the places that
it was wrong and that's what we have to
do
and part of that is going beyond
it worked or it didn't work right how do
we learn things where
with the things had a problem is because
first we're willing to recognize there
are places where our forecasts messed up
but we're not just saying oh yeah it all
sucks right we
there were some things that worked and
some didn't and i would like you to
think of this talk as a model
for how you can proceed in the problems
that you work on
and that is all thank you
another classic no slides talk from
andrew gellman
i hope everyone enjoyed that as much as
they have enjoyed him in previous years
as a good uh barn burner i didn't get
much controversy out of that one way to
get them in a
post-conference interview so that brings
us up to our first
you